[Música]
vaninho os fóruns da importância da
observar a terra a partir do espaço
a primeira porque quero dizer o primeiro
porque é que observamos em qual é a
necessidade que temos de observar a
terra a partir do espaço
como é que fazemos fazemos mais nós
usamos a aal salvar a terra viva o
futebol e principalmente no futuro o
futuro desta área que se encontra em
franco crescimento no qual é um prazer
poder contribuir com o santos pelo gol
então porque vamos começar então pelo
porque basicamente por um citamos a aã ã
o os seres humanos estão na terra cinta
onde comer necessitam de água potável
água potável como provavelmente sabem é
não é assim tão abundante do mundo
embora ou o ofício terra seja coberta da
água é que a porcentagem da água potável
não é assim então é tão grande que
tivemos nos fera precisamos atmosfera
para nos dar a nossa temperatura
ambiente
uns anos viveram e oxigênio para
respirar e precisamos nos proteger
contra a aa a contração em termos
estruturais com trovões contra tsunamis
portanto precisamos da terra e
precisamos saber o que podemos contar
com ela em pleno dia e monitorizada
nível global
a idéia importância conseguir observar a
terra a com a partir do espaço de forma
global
isto permite que nós contribuímos para
manter uma relação saudável e
sustentavam com menos ganhei com e com
as pessoas à nossa volta
neste âmbito os seus unidas em 98 a
adotaram um conjunto de objetivos
desenvolvimento sustentável e souza
jadson 17 objetivos a estes dois
objetivos a serem adotados novos
observou observação da terra possa usar
a uma contribuição muito significativa
para monitorizar a várias quantidades
estão associadas a estes objetivos e
subjetivos tolson são muito variados não
vou passar por todos
temos por exemplo a iluminação da forma
a nível mundial a a ação climática a
vida na terra filha do submarino e por
aí fora
o grupo do jornal só vai fazer uma uma
instituição animal a um mundial tem a
opção de sair mas sempre isso em que
conheceu o pai um dos grandes
consumidores e até exatamente como
missão contribuir para
a ajudar as nações unidas chegaram sim
todos os carros a isso objetivos num
prazo de uma década e maia
mais ou menos o max é um projecto limpar
portugal que a contribuição do gesel
para do país através do museu para estes
três objectivos e tem como objetivo a
puxar pela utilização dos meios de
observação da terra em prol do profisco
global
além disso é por isso que nós precisamos
observar a terra para continuar a manter
uma relação saudável e sustentável
manter ou melhorar ainda se possível
como é que fazemos fazemos através do
espaço fazemos com satélites está esta
imagem imagem da estação espacial
internacional
este é o maior objeto alguma vez posto
em órbita seus humanos tanto o maior
satélite comercial continua em órbita c4
que vamos altura e em permanente
habitado por humanos
a tripulação nacional com vários novatos
é um dos maiores exemplos são o maior
exemplo de cooperação internacional é
muito bem sucedida
temos temos também para para fazer essa
população e principalmente frota de
satélites de observação da terra e os
funcionários que só dois últimos lotes
que não estava muito importante a
agência espacial européia já deixou o
trabalho continua a a aumentar mas já
não funciona mas foi muito importante na
história da agência espacial está em
forma e também do de um autocarro em uma
troca muito bem equipado e foi um dos
ramos um ponto importante para a agência
européia
o vasco vai lançar um satélite americano
é dos anos 80 mil dos satélites landsat
observação da terra mais americano e
teve um papel extremamente importante na
área adaptação na terra não só pelo tão
tão usados em si mas principalmente
porque em 2008 a nasa resolveu
distribuir os dados como o twitcam é
gratuita e é aberto e gratuito
portanto é a remoção dos dados de
observação da terra em cadeias de
a suporta a a decisão a aumentou
exponencialmente não podem ver no
gráfico de 2008 ou quantidade de dados a
serem usados
mithyuê e ivan dodig sinal de fazer
basicamente tinham fotografias tinham a
imagem e outras candidatos relacionados
com o suficiente até este aqui é muito
mais antiga do ano passado
amã câmera fotográfica com as cores
alteradas em que se pode ver um vórtice
de drogas
eu acho ainda assim mas é lindíssimo e
procure observar a escala da imagem
no piauí um ponto branco com uma risca
um barco em que o barco está a entrar
num filme que eu praticamente não vê
localmente mas que o aumento se consegue
ver que é um filme extremamente
interessante e tem imensas implicações
tanto na área da pesca da agricultura ea
eventual e e inclusivamente na área de
monitorização marítima
esta é uma imagem conta com diferentes
têm sabe até em free pizza do galardão e
que consegue se viram a subsistência do
sol só consegue ser alterações no sul do
sol até o nível de incentivo do milênio
aquela zona tem mais amarelada e
avalizaram o tenha estação de comboios
jorge que entre 2004 e 2010 a isso
afundou cerca de 15 em 2010 foi possível
ver em mim e foi descoberto através das
imagens de satélite com fã há algum grau
do funcionamento desta desta situação e
estão com tanto através do satélite e
agora eu só o futuro não só o futuro
temos numa altura muito interessante
muito importante para a população nessa
tela estamos na altura do planeta altura
em que a comissão do país avançarem e
lançou o container e irá continuar a
fazer os serviços de satélite neste
programa o técnico que é um problema
global na sua terra e que ponha europa
na liderança da desta área
às 16 horas até hoje expostas atualmente
com 1 com dois gols que na prática são
do satélite e eu mais uma compra de
terra e garantir pela primeira vez a
consciência de dados possam negociar até
agora que a demissão era grande até o
fim até acabar 178 disso não
neste momento quando não a doença
sempre órbita por um falha com o seu pai
um compromisso com deus quando lhes
permite que sejam desenvolvidas inúmeras
aplicações e que haja consistência e se
possa acreditar que o que existe agora
existem que dez anos
além disso a quantidade de dados gerados
por esta por esse sistema é enorme
do lado do ptb de 10 petabytes por ano
que é é um dos maiores sistemas de
fornecimento de dados não só nesta área
mas em geral há aqui boas um gráfico do
do crescimento também no número de
satélites teve com o mercado privado
também táxi irã antes principalmente
neste momento está foram já várias
construções de vários cursos de gestão
serão a ser formadas portanto também do
lado o número de satélites é
extremamente interessante nos o curioso
é que esta questão gráfica do valor do
dólar em função do valor tanto na área
dos dados que é a parte branca quanto na
área dos serviços web de valor
acrescentado ricos nada que um valor
total a ser transferido dos dados para o
serviço 911 e visa mais tarde uma
esquerda que os atos são mais fáceis de
ser europa e estados unidos já tiveram
os dados de graça e mesmo a nível
privado os custos baixaram e portanto
tão unidade estão a tornar uma commodity
e o foco está neste momento em
desenvolver sistemas e aplicações para
para o governo poder aproveitar estes
dados e transformá-los em conhecimento e
apoio à decisão
há até mesmo a tecnologia não vou entrar
na partida e ecologia na mesa da cozinha
de big data então ser herdadas por esta
presta área de visualização foco numa
muito importante que a parte da
participação dos cidadãos
a observação da terra não se esgota ujs
e os cidadãos estão a participar muito
com um passe que saiu só eu tirar a
informação no cálcio gostosona am da
saúde vai complementar muito bem as
cidades satélites na partilha e
aplicações êxito com a decisão mostra
que uma um esforço feito pela plaza em
estudar e perceber muito bem o nível a
alteração do nível do mar
tudo está aumentado podem ver gráfico em
baixo à direita é a que o aumento médio
com é bastante
é bastante real anos mais do que isso
com sexo verão e isso é um conjunto
noção de algoritmos sofisticados
baseados em dados de satélites são a
fantasia muito talento e podem ver aqui
que o aumento do nível do mar não é
homogêneo só está a atravessar as vias
têm que se preocupar mais cedo que o
trânsito aumenta especialmente mal tá tá
tá junto à costa mas não é das mais
afetadas não lese é engraçado pior
[Música]
esta é a imagem uma imagem kaká que foi
um sistema de previsão de colheitas do
do sábado do dos estados unidos tudo foi
como empresa privada que conseguiram com
algoritmos de direita
neste caso particular de plugin que
conhecem área e uma forma avançada não
ganhar 200 normais e conseguiram a
bater-nos previsões de colheitas
norte-americanas para para o ano de 2016
quando isto foi só com dados de satélite
e com os amigos por cima de tudo isso
foi a a a outra está a ser um caso
bastante entrada de mata para a
utilização que tem implicações não só
nos estados unidos e na europa mas
principalmente em cima tudo tem estado a
a áfrica subsaariana em que a escassez
de documentação é bastante grande
portanto este prover antecipadamente a
este tipo de crédito é bastante
importante para as instituições
internacionais não foi internacional por
emergir a atempadamente e portanto isto
é basicamente aquilo que podemos fazer
com observação da terra e há muito mais
a base da operação terra monitorização
do nosso planeta é isso que eu penso que
tenho que fazer ouvida e é é isso que
neste momento está completamente
a ser feito e que será utilizado e além
disso existe também uma mãe que sentaria
aplicações individuais o que foi
possível dar um em que não sabe que em
qualquer outra área de projeções abertas
com com a a disponibilidade de dados não
sabe exatamente o que vai sair no futuro
mas o conto que provavelmente alguns
vocês vão acabar pura por trazer
inovação nesta área
muito obrigado
[Aplausos]